[Music]
I just don't think you understand how
Tinder Works can I tell you something I
know exactly how Tinder works you don't
understand how flirting
[Music]
Works how do you think you got
here it hurts where
honey
everywhere
[Music]
unique you made my head silent who are
you talking to can you please just come
out so she can see you
mam you need to say goodbye to your
lord you have to get strong now I can't
you can and you have to let me help you
life every life
ends I felt the pain that you
[Music]
have I don't know uh what I am without
you who I am without
you I don't know what the world is
without you in
it I love you more
than anything in the whole
world you'll be okay
yes
promise promise promise
[Music]
promise the echo you leave the Legacy
your memory is how she
[Music]
lives